Steven twitch boss is the star of a new
Gap campaign
[Music]
prior to his sudden death in December
the choreographer showed off his
modeling skills in an ad for gap's
limited edition collab with the Brooklyn
circus a haitian-owned menswear line
that's Twitch dancing laughing and
smiling for the camera as he models the
capsule collection the emotions that
come to mind are really just I mean
happiness
in other snaps from the photo shoot
twitch Dons a vintage inspired letterman
jacket cuffed pants and black shoes and
in this close-up the late star rocks a
white button-up shirt with a wide
brimmed hat your individuality is way
more than enough in a press release
shared on Monday twitch's wife Allison
holker opened up about the project
praising the ad for capturing her late
husband's true Essence I have the
sweetest husband in the entire world and
Allison explained that when she and
twitch first saw the pics it brought
tears to their eyes
he was excited for the world to see them
we pay tribute to Steven's Life by
sharing these images in homage to the
joy and light he brought to everyone
around him we're celebrating and
continue to give love continue to give
laughs in honor of twitch the fashion
brands are donating to vibrant emotional
health an organization helping those in
distress without access to life-saving
counseling therapy or support
twitch died by suicide in December he
was 40 years old earlier this month
Allison shared an emotional tribute on
Instagram writing to my husband best
friend babe Chi Chalker Superman and
father of my children I love you forever
and always the way we approach life is
we kind of look at life as being our
playground Allison and twitch have two
children together six-year-old son
Maddox and three-year-old daughter ziya
twitch is also dad to Allison's 14 year
old daughter Wesley from a previous
relationship we love the Full House and
also just like family man like honestly
they're my favorite they're my favorite
people you know what I mean Allison
added that they will forever remember
twitch as a true Beacon of light before
thanking him for the memories and
Beautiful Life they shared together I
feel like we connect a lot through dance
so it's just sometimes fun like to have
a partner in life that I can also dance
with you know it just makes every single
day so fun Allison later shared this
clip dancing around the house with
twitch alongside the caption our love
language
I Wanna Get To Know
[Music]